du rire de la réflexion et des échanges
une soixantaine de professionnels
invités par la ville de plaisir
partagent leur expérience de travail
avec plusieurs générations pour cette
employée de la mairie le bienfait du
lien entre les populations ne fait aucun
doute
moi je suis amené à travailler avec les
enfants et le fait que ça passe par des
aux aînés ou des personnes en tout cas
plus âgés que les enfants il ya un côté
beaucoup plus
éducatif les participants de ce tout
premier forum doivent trouver des idées
pour renforcer encore le contact entre
générations repas spectacle cours
d'informatique
tout est évoquée est alors une idée là
qui m'a séduite qui a été évoqué en fin
de groupe de travail qui serait de faire
un théâtre de rue en faisant participer
les habitants jeunes et moins jeunes et
en essayant de réunir au maximum les
quartiers de la ville les élus de
plaisir l'ont bien constaté les liens
entre les habitants de la ville
s'effrite et paradoxalement notre monde
hyperconnecté n'arrange rien on
communique mais est-ce qu'on échange
véritablement je suis pas certaine les
réseaux sociaux on s'envoie des petits
messages
on se parle c'est très bref ça y'a pas
de je pense que l'on on a perdu ce lien
avec les réseaux sociaux les meilleures
idées de cette journée de travail seront
présentées au conseil municipal de
plaisir à la rentrée en vue d'être
appliquée dès l'an prochain